Hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to the
first
one of my many Doctor Who Series 8 Q&As. Hopefully I'll be doing this on a
regular basis
but since this is my first let's all have a
Drink!
So most of the questions you guys have
are about
what's gonna be the old stuff
that they're bringing back and what's
going to be some other new stuff that
they're gonna introduce during Series 8.
So I picked 10 of your questions and as a
special bonus one just for fun at the
end.
Real quick announcement: Since
Matt Smith is officially gone I'll be
changing my Channel Avatar sometime soon
it won't be Peter Capaldi, it'll be a
cartoon version my face. I have
absolutely no idea what's gonna look
like
but I'm talking to my favorite artists to
figure it out. So I'll be sure to keep you
guys updated.
Also because we're starting to learn
things from the set of Series 8 I'm going
to start doing videos for that too.
So I'll proobably do a video next week explaining some things we've learned based
on the scenes they shot outside last week.
Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get that! Alright so
let's get started, Don't worry, I'll be drinking
during this.
Question 1
Ryan Nicholson asks what do you think
about the rumors of an Easter Special?
So there was actually a rumor of an
Easter Special last year when they were
talking about Series 8.
Nothing has been said about it since, and
obviously you think the BBC would spend
some time marketing it if they want to get
people excited about a full hour of the
brand new Doctor.
So I don't think it's gonna happen, it's
possible that they might do a webisode.
It's more likely that we'll get a
regular Christmas Special.
Question #2: Vegtabadass asks:
Do you think will see the return the
Master in Series 8 and if he
regenerates, who would you pick to play him?
So there haven't been any confirmations
or denials of the Master coming back.
Jon Simm is totally capable playing the
role, but if he is coming back and just
doesn't want to play the character anymore,
some really awesome choices might be
Jason Isaacs from Harry Potter,
Dan Stevens from Downton Abbey or maybe
even a Idris Elba, but they'll be totally
awesome but I'm not expecting the care
to come back
question number three Lydia Subrosa ask
would you be opposed to having an
American actor appearance series 8 until
they open to anyone appearing on the
show is another good actor and the
characters are interesting
the reason why is largely a British cass
is because it using the UK's
for practical reasons question number
four Jack O'Connor asks
if Peter Jackson work to direct an
episode in series 8
what sort of plot would you have them
bring to life so it's looking less and
less likely that Pierre Jackson is
actually gonna have a time to direct
Doctor Who
but if he did he would totally have to
do a period piece and something with
some really awesome creatures
think it is being like Doctor Who Lord
of the Rings or you know like
order the tortoises or something like
that he is a big fan adaalat
so he could always be the person to
bring da lights back to question number
five
mark Brea tasks could the similarities
with
three have something to do with Tom
Baker saying he'll revisit all faces
see talking about the similarities in
his costume honestly I think the
revisiting all phases is just a wink and
a nod to
possibilities for future anniversary
specials topic was really just kinda
seeing the idea at that they could bring
back old classic doctors you know
all faces who are still alive question
number six latex 23 gaming asks
do you think the series 8 episode 1 will
have a new villain
or do you think an old on your return
Sony 11 there they had
two separate races appearing for the
first time at least on camera
there was the approxi- and then there
was that mystery bill and I don't think
they ever name with the race that was
some actually getting its gonna be
something similar to that question ever
seven
tear Davenport asks will go out for a
play into the plot yes but only in the
background
thinkin series 8 is having three main
types a story is so the a story will be
whatever the new Big John plot is
you like the sounds during serious 6 now
be like the a plot the be plot will be
the Gallifrey plot
I'm not expecting them to find out
prayer to fix the solution during series
in the sea plot that third one would
just be the week to week problems the
doctor solves wherever he ends up going
which number eight Selina see asks well
River song's role in series
eight-b_ so out skin thin day whatever
classic
spoilers lines just a tease fans you
know wearing a River Song
type cost him there have been no
confirmation from Steven Moffat or the
BBC that she's going to be featured
though
the best theory that I've seen so far is
that her consciousness is actually
stored in the people mainframe
that we saw during the Christmas special
and should get out that way question
number nine
brown put forty-eight asks will compile
the use matts masonic
sometimes the colors just change but
typically every new doctor gets a new
site so yes
pick a party for all intensive purposes
will get a new sonic
the TARDIS interior will not change
though is but a couple million dollars
making that one during the 2012
Christmas special
son I can do that again anytime soon
think about it this way Peter campanis
out that will change before the TARDIS
changes again
and last my number ten this one's a fun
one more production asks
do you think the benefit coverage would
make a good potential master
so yes absolutely there's no 1i have met
who did not think that Sherlock would
make the best person to the master
but just to give you an idea benicar
batch is one of the busiest actors out
there so even if he was totally down to
play the role
you know johnson didn't wanna play it
again heap I wouldn't be able to do it
just for scheduling reasons
took them two years to make sure like
series 3 just because Benedict
Cumberbatch Martin Freeman were shooting
so many movies
that's how busy is thank you so much for
submitting your questions guys is a lot
of fun
hopefully I'll do this on a regular
basis I do a Q&A every week but my next
Doctor Who video will be up production
related video
I might also do a video for my top five
yr top 10 picks for a new master even if
he doesn't appear in the new series
be sure to subscribe to get it I'm also
doing a row cuny tonight you can click
here to get that
anything click here to get my reactions
to pick apart his new outfit
thank you so much watching a CS tonight
have fives